where should one draw the line in terms
of political incorrectness following a
tragedy that is a great question is
probably in reference to our friend
Gilbert Gilbert who is a friend and yeah
I think Gilbert Gottfried and you and I
sometimes we define what is too far and
what Gilbert said hurt a lot of people's
feelings other people said it's just a
joke but this is the marketplace of free
ideas and you know I think but people I
don't know what too far is it's just
somebody goes that's an arguable point I
don't know the answer to that and
Gilbert is an idiot savant and an idiot
no he's he's brilliant and there's not a
mean bone in his body
right and he reflexively went for the
joke as many of us do some of us will
tell jokes and it's only return duck
they said um Gilbert you will brought
discredit upon a talking duck a [ __ ]
canard
and also Affleck has a lot of business
but it's also that he didn't I think
fully appreciate the magnitude of the
disaster at the time of course yeah you
know it's this objective humor is very
subjective so if people thought it was
really funny he probably wouldn't have
gotten what role he's a comedian so if
people don't find him funny they stop
listening to him if they do they're
laughing boys on the page of you know if
you don't like something turn the page
right but people have a sense of you
know they like to feel morally superior
especially especially in a situation
where they can't do anything right
themselves they feel bad and they can go
right for it you know I remember you
know after 9/11 when I lost my job but
you were doing a joke no right that's
the big difference right know what
you're like I will always take the hit
from the audience or anywhere if it's a
point that needs to be made right this
is just a tragedy there's no real point
that's I think that's also the
difference it is just sad
you know there's no point to be made
when I said what I said about terrorists
and everything I thought there was a
larger point right but okay well I just
did one thing I just want to say though
I do think it is a slippery slope
because if yes I mean I I don't think
what he said was funny or appropriate in
my opinion but I don't take Gilbert
Godfried seriously either so that's no
what the opinion she's not an opinion is
what I saw and what the official but I
really do think that I mean they know
that people use humor to cope in really
different whistling past the graveyard
and we know that there's it is a very
short time if we will start making jokes
Thank You jokes happen right away but we
were joking when the pieces of the
challenge are falling into the water but
we didn't do it on stage right we were
joking about everything out of grace
right and selectively just another
example of why how this technology is
not serving us maybe is that what we got
Twitter and it's not you say Wayne is
too quick it's very disseminate I don't
think that we were meant you man 'ti was
meant if there's a meaning to our
existence to know everything at once
it's going on in the world because of
the technology you mentioned we know
every disaster every disease every war
every suffering I mean you know my heart
goes out to Japan my heart goes out to
Katrina and the BP and the 9/11 first
responders I have no [ __ ] heart left
I mean it's it's compassion overload
Americans are on the verge of worlds on
the verge of a nervous breakdown we
don't know who to mourn for who do who
do we blame who dislike that's why I
think Obama has that I'm a discreet and
do some when you say you have no heart
left you have no heart to begin with
anyway I
oh right would you support a ballot
measures such as one proposed in San
Francisco that would outlaw male
circumcision ouch another one of those
things like Michelle Obama is against
desert right it's I know that there is a
faction of people who think that that's
somehow mutilation I don't know it's
pretty barbaric the only time I did it
one what a bris you know you know what's
barbarity [ __ ] by an uncircumcised
dick is in a porn movie and they're so
gross
you cannot never seen a dick I did not
have a problem I was married my first
marriage my husband was uncircumcised we
had a problem for well anytime I don't
know why we're legislating this right it
says one proposed in San Francisco there
was a correlation though between lack of
circumcision and some types of cancer
it's slight not 3,000 years ago because
quite the epidemiology smells cut it off
that's why they did it
that backfired which is why they didn't
want to have shellfish in the Bible
because people ate it and they got sick
right they didn't know they were ancient
people here's the solving of the problem
and when a baby's born
the surgeon upon taking the child the
male child out does a dorsal split that
sounds painful no it's not
when the baby comes out you do a door so
then you don't wait till it's like a few
weeks old take it to a synagogue put it
on a [ __ ] pastrami slice at home on
the pastrami spice with my son just one
make that clear I think it's interesting
though that this is an issue of in San
Francisco which I guess has a department
of penises or something that Gilbert
Godfried penises thank you very much
folks we'll see you next week